Black adam what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
and there are villains. heroes don't kill people
well i do
that's up to you
behind you
did he just catch a rocket
Welcome back everyone we totally smell what the
rock is cooking there's a brand new black adam
trailer so we'll break it all down they give us a
little bit of the story so i'll talk about what's
going on and all the connections to all the other
dc movies that are going on right now that are
especially connected to the justice league line
of continuity if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos so
starting at the beginning of the footage that
i'll work our way through shot by shot they open
on the shot of what looks like hawkman ship but
it could belong to this other group though they
have this mysterious tech based group that a lot
of people are confused thinking that it might
be argus but because hawkman talks about there
being two different groups in the city they're
heroes there are villains and when you see the
villains they show these tech based characters
here i'm assuming these are connected to the
forces of sabac at some point sabacc is a demon
based shazam villain that has powers that works
similar to the way that shazam and black adam's
powers work like they have a power word they draw
power from gods or demons sabach is a demon that
gives people power inside this special facility
you see this villain group putting this ancient
conduct figure into stasis i think this character
is meant to be connected to the sabach villain
like he is giving people power the same way that
black adam got power from the wizard shazam and
the other wizards of the council you get this
voiceover from dr fate's character questioning
black adam what have your powers ever given you
basically throwing everything in his face that he
did 5 000 plus years ago that got him locked up in
that magical prison by the wizard shazam that's
meant to be a reference to him being trapped
because of what happened with the seven deadly
sins the big prologue during the shazam movie
pierce brosnan playing our version of doctor
fate and the justice society inside the dc eu
obviously the justice society very different from
the justice league this movie's meant to establish
them they'll probably get some kind of spin-off
movie at some point i believe the way they're
explaining them in the movie is that something
crazy happened to their team in ancient history
like they're meant to be an older team the way
they portray them in the comics and dr fate and
hawkman are the only ones who have survived to
present day so the team is kind of in shambles
when the movie picks up and the newer younger
members like cyclone and adam smasher wind up
helping reform a new version of the team in
present day we see a little bit of dr fate
using his powers wearing the helmet of naboo the
thing is is he can take the helmet off but he's
basically a prisoner to the power of the helmet in
the power of this avatar of order the whole thing
with the dr fake character is he's an avatar of
the gods of order there's the gods of chaos they
get into a lot of that mythology during the young
justice series they also did a live-action version
of dr fate during the small veil series a billion
years ago usually they portray the powers of the
helmet the wielder of dr fate's powers as a curse
not a blessing so he's kind of telling black adam
in this scene that it's been like that with his
powers too they've kind of been more of a curse
than a blessing the whole idea is they spend this
trailer trying to convince him that he should help
kondok he should help the world not destroy it
remember they're trying to use the rock with this
movie as an anti-hero but obviously eventually
they have to do black adam versus shazam so
there's lots of quote unquote disagreements that
he has with other traditional superheroes like we
can't wait to see him fight superman at some point
because superman is weak against magic so just be
a really interesting fight he narrates a little
bit of his backstory five thousand plus years
ago in conduct he said he was born into slavery
he did have a family but they wound up dying at
the hands of these really terrible slave masters
when he says his son died to save him that's a bit
of a twist on the comic book origin if you read
the newer versions of the origin story which the
shazam movie borrowed from they did some of black
adam's origin story during that but instead of
doing it during the shazam movie they just said
that there was too much going on that's why they
separated the black adam stuff in that story to
this separate movie but in the trailer when he
says his son died to save him it sounds like the
slave master is getting ready to kill him and his
son does something to intervene and winds up dying
instead then he says he died and was reborn of god
so it sounds like he gets the power of shazam
somehow when he's in the process of dying like
his son dies while he is in the process of dying
and the power passes to him then they show him
in modern day this is obviously after he's been
released from his magical tomb that the wizard
put him in by sarah shahi's character all these
men with guns inside the tomb that are trying
to get sarah shahi's character seem like they're
connected to the sabach villain or they might be
another minor villain group the whole idea is
that in present day kondok has fallen to ruin
and there's just another warlord ruling over
the area it sounds like that's connected to the
sabac villain character but there could be just a
bunch of other groups taking advantage of the area
as you can see his power looks very similar to
shazam's power his costume looks very similar
to shazam's costume because they get their power
from the same person from the same place now in
the comics originally the black adam acronym means
something different from the shazam acronym it's
the same basic principle it's just that they draw
power from different places the powers themselves
work very similar though they have the same power
word they say shazam they activate their powers or
they deactivate them but because there's this
big shared history between the characters the
rock of eternity and the wizard shazam there'll
probably be some sort of moment during the film
or some post-credit scene where they connect them
i believe the next movie after shazam 2 fury of
the gods and after the black adam movie that will
be your big crossover shazam vs black adam film
there was a funny video of the rock driving
around in his golf cart just yelling curse words
just getting really excited about his trailer
being released you have to imagine it's the
shazamly that black adam is dragging behind
him on that card he will wreck them during
that movie when they have this indiana jones
looking scene where sarah shahi releases him
from his prison you have these special rocks
here there's a crown floating in the air that
they show i believe that's meant to be the crown
of sabac just according to reports about the movie
something the villain group is trying to obtain
that will make them more powerful i'm assuming
because black adam's prison is so near where
this other main artifact that the villains want
is because the wizard shazam when he trapped
black adam also put this crown here jaime hansu
is supposed to appear at some point during the
film as a younger version of the wizard i think
they'll have a flashback to explain how he trapped
him in this prison this is hawkman stanigarian
ship you see hawkman's symbol all over the place
it's all made of nth metal and technology from the
thanagarians they were going to have hawk women
in the movie at one point but the rock basically
said that another project another dc movie or tv
show was going to use her they wound up using the
cyclone character instead for that most of you
are at least a little familiar with hawkman's
character it's basically what you think it is he's
a character who's resurrected but i don't know how
they're going to explain his backstory if it'll be
the one that you've seen in live action before but
because there's all the stanigary technology that
seems like it's from another planet it sounds like
they're going to incorporate the whole hawk world
the world of thanagar stuff into the movie as well
obviously his whole thing is that he resurrects
every time he dies and that is connected to
the power of the nth metal this is atom smasher
they did a live action version during the flash
a bunch of years ago that you probably saw but
this is a much younger version of the character
obviously he's not meant to be evil or anything
like that his technology for changing his size
seems like it's really old-timey so he might just
be a subsequent version of the character who's
taken up the mantle from the previous atom smasher
we see some of the powers of the justice society
as they all jump out of hawkman's ship have this
big battle with the villain group cyclone's powers
are exactly what you think she's shown up in the
justice society comics before she's a relatively
minor character but it sounds like they try to
give her a bit of an upgrade especially with
her costume during this movie hawkman and black
adam have this big scene him trying to take him
to task about killing people even villains saying
heroes don't do that they're trying to use this
as one of the big tag lines of the movie one of
his big mottos like heroes don't kill people but
i kill people you see black adam try to save sarah
shahi's character and this other person from these
thugs within the context of present day they're
obviously meant to be a proxy for his family in
ancient times sarah shahi is playing the character
who becomes his love interest in present day the
young kid i think might wind up being her brother
if they're doing the comics in the comics there is
an arc where he does share some of his power with
these characters the same way that shazam shares
his power with the rest of his family but because
black adam is viewed as more of a villain more
of an anti-hero things kind of go off the rails
when he does stuff like that dr fate talks about
witnessing the future using his power and seeing
a couple different possibilities black adam either
pulls off his own version of the evil superman
plot from the justice league snyder cut sequels
where he basically conquers the entire world and
winds up killing or enslaving most of the other
heroes i've already done a billion videos about
the justice league snyder cut sequels plot because
we found out what he was going to be doing for
each of those sequels so i'll post that link down
in the description but then dr faith says the
other possibility the other future that he saw
is black adam helping the world become better this
is just another action scene with black adam going
up against some of the other villain characters
from this sabbat group you see a city-wide escape
though with a statue that looks like it was
a statute to him then they just have a couple
funny moments about how powerful he really is how
much damage he can actually sow the big joke about
him catching the missile not really understanding
what kind of weapon it is because he's so old he's
just come out of prison the way they explain his
power level during this is that he's meant to be
the most powerful that he will ever become like
there is no power up that he is seeking to obtain
so he's meant to be as powerful as superman
during this potentially this is meant to be set
after the events of the justice league snyder
cut movie this is a dc eu movie because it's
connected to shazam and he is connected to henry
cavill superman obviously but what'll happen is
they're actually releasing shazam 2 right after
the black adam movie during this same year so we
won't have to wait that long before we find out
what's happening during shazam 2 and what's going
on with their big crossover if you did spot any
easter eggs during the trailer that i didn't talk
about during the video or any big plot points just
let me know in the comments i'm sure there's going
to be some questions about what's going on with
this character as we get the next couple trailers
the movie's coming out in october so we
will get another trailer later this summer
i'm working on my ms marvel episode 1 video
right now too that should post tomorrow morning
while you wait for that everyone click here for my
full obi-wan kenobi episode 4 video in easter eggs
and click here for my brand new thor love
and thunder trailer video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and
i'll see you guys in the next one!